our poll also finds no real change in
the president's job rating 36 percent
said they approve of his performance and
58 percent disapprove that's about the
same as two months ago the Trump
administration is studying a draft
report on climate change that was leaked
to the New York Times the research by 13
federal agencies says it's possible to
attribute some extreme weather to
climate change
they say average US temperatures have
risen rapidly since 1980 and are now the
warmest in 1,700 years major Garrett is
near the trump National Golf Club in
Bedminster New Jersey major good morning
good morning president Trump skepticism
about the link between global warming
and greenhouse gas emissions is
well-known now this report awaits White
House release and the lack of comment
from officials here and from those at
some of the relevant federal agencies
about this report startling conclusions
suggest not just skepticism but at least
initially a lack of curiosity a lot of
it's a hoax it's a hoax mr. Trump has a
history of challenging the science
behind climate change including one
suggesting quote the concept of global
warming was created by and for the
Chinese but a draft report from 13
federal agencies asserts the impact of
climate change is being felt right now
creating higher temperatures and even
causing some extreme weather events I do
not believe that climate change is a
hoax
Scott Pruett administrator for the
Environmental Protection Agency was
forced to admit during his confirmation
hearing that he does not believe climate
change is made up but since being
confirmed by the Senate Pruitt has
questioned human involvement I think
that that measuring with precision human
activity on the climate is something
very challenging to do and there's
tremendous disagreement about that the
degree of impact but the report awaiting
the White House's approval states that
many lines of evidence demonstrate that
human activities especially emissions of
greenhouse gases are primarily
responsible for recent observed climate
change I was elected to represent the
citizens of Pittsburgh
not Paris in June president Trump pulled
out of the Paris climate Accords a
global agreement aimed at reducing
greenhouse gas emissions the president
said the decision was to protect
American jobs and he promised to protect
the environment gonna have the cleanest
air we're gonna have the cleanest water
we will be environmentally friendly but
we're not going to put our businesses
out of work when the president touts the
biggest achievements of his
administration so far many are in the
area of regulations repealing or rolling
back those dealing with the environment
from the Obama administration and
expanding the extraction of fossil fuels
Charlie the administration relentlessly
argues that those regulations did far
more economic harm than environmental
good major thanks